why was she in every interview with you
because that's one thing my mom did not
do that that's one thing I didn't ever
see I mean why did she ever explain to
you why she would sit next to you in
interviews no it was just the way it
should be it was No One's Gonna Get You
I'm gonna I'm gonna be there I'm I'm
there first you're mine I'm not gonna
give you to somebody
and I'll protect you I'll answer under
the guise of protection but it was more
ownership and fear I I think she was the
original
momager if you will and my mom became a
manager in honor of Terry Shields
because she was known in the industry as
the great protector of you the the one
who called the shots and yet I paid the
rent you paid the rent have you how do
you feel about that you know then and
now it was all I knew you know what I
mean we but we got stuff
it's like I did a movie and we got a car
we got a car too and my mom couldn't
afford one otherwise no all I knew was
keep my mother alive keep dancing and
get stuff but to emerge from it not
angry or jaded no is in there it's
something in your character it's in my
character doing this documentary
um has it's given me a life and the most
interesting way what do we say to young
girls who are out there on Instagram on
social media doing the same things we
did so we're not judging it I'm not
judging it I did it too I get it but
now knowing what we know
they're not going to listen yes I know I
wouldn't
I would never
so you know Ali's a really good one for
this like she's she's got a really great
perspective on it and and Ali Wentworth
who's her best friend and the producer
of this who we're gonna invite out in a
minute
but you know they're gonna have to
process it on their own because they
think they're in control
but then the flip side is they'll say oh
I can't be alone with that with that boy
in that in the you know whatever room
because he's gonna then expect something
yeah and you're just like okay you don't
get to be that woke and then still say
this so you're gonna have to try to
balance it but you just keep talking
keep talking to them and our experience
is completely unrelatable
I mean the the documentary is so
incredibly well crafted with your life's
journey in photos and film and behind
the scenes that it is literally like you
are there with you and you don't have to
like me to watch it like do you know
what I mean like it's not it's not like
a fan it's not like a a retrospective
and like you have to be a fan and then
you care like it's about a bigger story
and it's about a female story and a
female journey and finding your voice
finding your agency whenever it is I
don't think there's actually been a
better time for it because now girls are
in the position we were in growing up
that was so rare and unique and they are
putting themselves have access to and
portals too the same thing we went
through as kids and I think it's going
to be a Tipping Point in the culture of
how we all discuss the new normal with
our kids growing up in front of
everybody just the way we did and I have
to ask you like now that the documentary
is out has any of like the male
directors like reached out to Louis Mal
and Franco zafarelli they're both dead
you know I the director of the Blue
Lagoon is still alive he did send me a
he I saw his name on my phone and I was
like oh oh what do I do and I let it go
to voicemail because I was like oh I
want to see what the tone is and it he
wants to chat I don't know about what I
don't feel like bringing any of it up
back up again and like it's not about
that you know um but it's a it was
it was about you know these males
needing me to be in a certain category
to serve their story and it never was
about me it never it was not never
protective of me it was fun and loving
at times but it was
I was a I was just there I was a pawn
but these men like Keith Carradine took
such good care of me he looked at me and
he said you know this doesn't count as a
first kiss right that was gracious and
protective and caring on a level that I
don't even think I knew at the time I'd
never kissed a boy before how in the
hell did this ever got gotten away with
by the way did like I was so confused
about sexuality because then my mom like
went and dated my boyfriends did you
ever have that weird situation with your
mom
um no because she was in love with me I
was her main focus
and both of us were going to be cut off
from our sexuality I was going to stay a
virgin
she was going to be just Terry terrific
and being there so it's like there were
I mean well yeah that's another
conversation and I think my mom might
have been so enamored with me that she
actually wanted to be with the people I
was with I
I don't get it but I get it it's it's so
layered and it's so needy and it's so
sad and broken we're sitting here
laughing about the fact that our moms
are so in love with us that they behaved
so absolutely inappropriately and we
have our sense of humor intact and I
love us for that I do I love us for that
and there are moms and they gave us
look and if my mom hadn't schlepped me
to every audition and become my manager
I might not be sitting here right now
and there's nowhere on Earth I'd rather
be but you know what you think anybody
would be doing a documentary if I didn't
have the trajectory I did I don't know
but let's ask your best friend Ali
Wentworth he lived a totally different
life growing up so she has another
perspective and she helped make this
film and it is so powerful let's talk to
Ali we're going to bring her out
[Music]
thank you